hey guys it's justine and you might
notice that i am well i'm not in a field
i'm actually in front of the steve jobs
theater i am in cupertino right now and
wwdc just finished and i'm so excited
because they decided to do it in person
this year it was a limited invite there
still were a bunch of people here and
it's been so incredible to get to see
all of my friends and just so many
smiling happy apple people it's a dream
come true wwdc is the worldwide
developers conference and this is where
we kind of find out what we have to look
forward to an upcoming year of software
development a bunch of developers are
here and they get access to the beta
software like ios 16 which i can't
believe ios 16 is the next release so
i'm going to go through some of the
things that they announced and talked
about in the keynote today and it was so
much fun to actually be here in person
and get to experience this again and of
course a lot of you guys at home got a
chance to also watch it live first
things first um can we just talk about
the m2 chip i think this is something
that a lot of us have been waiting for
because obviously the m1 was so
revolutionary when they announced the m1
chip about two years ago they said there
was going to be a two-year transition
out of intel chips into apple silicon
and
since that we're coming up on the
two-year mark i would say in a couple of
months perhaps the apple silicon chip
the m1 the m1 ultra the m1 i mean it has
by far exceeded all of my expectations
more than i ever thought that it would
so i'm very excited to check out the m2
chip and they did announce some hardware
here at wwdc they announced the new
13-inch macbook pro and the new macbook
air and what's exciting about the
macbook air is it's an all-new unibody
design so it's no longer kind of that
little slanted design it basically looks
like like a mini macbook pro like it's
just like super super squished the new
macbook air m2 comes in four colors
there's a silver space gray starlight
and midnight and this is an all new
aluminum unibody 20
reduction in volume it's a half an inch
and they have magsafe which is so
exciting because before if you'd want to
charge your macbook air that would then
take away one of your ports so this
still has the two thunderbolt ports and
you won't have to take one of those away
to charge it also has the 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack that will support high
impedance headphones which is very
exciting especially if you're doing a
lot of audio work or video this will
make everything sound
just right so there's a 13.6 inch liquid
retina display it's 500 nits which is 25
brighter than the previous model it also
has a 1080p facetime camera which has 2x
the resolution and low light performance
it has all-day battery life up to about
18 hours and a starting price at 11.99
now that wasn't the only macbook that
they announced the 13-inch macbook pro
also got a little upgrade with the m2
chip that 13-inch macbook was something
that completely changed my life and
really showed me the power of the m1
chip so that is now also getting an
update to the m2 chip the 13-inch
macbook pro m2 has an 8-core cpu 10-core
gpu 40 faster gaming performance this
will give you about 20 hours of video
playback 24 gigs of unified memory up to
a 2 terabyte solid state drive and a
starting price at 12.99 i can't wait to
test out both of these macbooks because
i just can't even stress enough how
impressed i've been with the m1 so the
m2 can only go up from here which it
does
so that was some of the hardware that
was announced now let's go into the
software which is really what wwdc is
all about ios 16 my friends i love ios
updates because it basically gives you a
brand new phone without having to get a
brand new phone so one of my favorite
features that they announced in ios 16
is in imessages and i feel like imessage
is where i shine i really i'm not going
to lie to you i don't really look at my
email as much as i should most of the
time most of my communication happens in
imessages so something that they finally
announced i think a lot of people are
either excited about this or kind of on
the fence about it is message undo you
can also go back and make an edit and
this is something that i am very excited
about is message unread for me when i'm
going through like my messages if
there's a conversation that i need to
get back to i would love to be able to
mark that as unread just as a note to
myself to go back and make sure i
respond they also announced a new lock
screen this is something that we did see
in the rumors so you'll be able to
customize it much like you're able to
customize the apple watch faces and it's
kind of cool because it is basically
that same tech but now on your lock
screen you can change colors you can
change fonts you can change the photos
and they even have kind of like a lock
screen gallery with different
backgrounds and different kind of
templates that you can use so i can't
wait to try that out they also showed
some notifications that will now kind of
roll up from the bottom which i thought
was kind of interesting and i also feel
like if i'm holding my phone that would
be the perfect place to actually click
on the notifications because that's
where your thumb placement is there were
some talks of the new updated share play
which you can now actually do in
imessages so if you guys are watching a
movie together you don't have to
actually do it on facetime you could do
that through imessage they also made
some updates to apple wallet i know for
me i am so obsessed with digital
identification so this is slowly rolling
out state by state so it's not
everywhere yet it's not in california
which i cannot wait because you'll be
able to share your id with various apps
so if i ordered some alcohol from
ubereats or something like that i would
be able to share that i was over 21. i
wouldn't actually have to share how old
i am oh thank god sorry they would just
know that yes she is old enough she can
receive this alcohol so things like that
i think are really really interesting
they also have for apple pay they set it
up so that now if you are to purchase
something and you don't want to pay the
full amount now you can pay it over time
in four equal payments which i think is
really cool if you're making some big
purchases and you don't want to have to
pay for it all at once they're calling
this apple pay later which
i don't think that you could have come
up with a better name because it's
actually literally what you're doing
you're paying later another thing that i
thought was awesome is live techs i love
live text i have used this in so many
random scenarios if i'm watching tv and
i sometimes see something that i can't
actually see i will take a picture of it
pause the show zoom in on my phone and
it basically will give you all of that
text that you can then copy and paste
and they're even talking about how
they're going to have new translations
and you'll be able to touch and lift an
image
from a photo they did this little demo
where they like took a picture of this
dog and then lifted the dog off and then
pasted it into imessages can't wait to
also try that out just assume if i say
something i'm excited to try it out
apple maps of course is also getting an
update they've expanded to 11 more
countries they've improved the
animations and detailed graphics of city
landscapes and they have multi-stop
routing this is incredible i think they
said that you can go up to like 15
different stops so you can basically
plan your whole trip across the united
states in one sitting okay okay okay now
on to apple watch because you all know
that i absolutely love this thing one of
the things that i was really excited
about is they mentioned that they have
some new running features and as a i'm
not like a professional runner like a
subpar runner i'm kind of excited about
this because this is giving you all new
ways to train and push yourself but also
keep yourself accountable you're able to
measure stride length ground contact
time and vertical oscillation plus they
have some new workout options that will
let you focus on speed endurance or time
intervals i also like that they have a
feature that will let you track your
progress on a route that you frequently
run so you'll be able to actually see if
you're making progress in your training
there's also four new watch faces
there's the new siri ui and there's new
banner notifications because if you'll
notice if you've ever used your apple
watch that it takes up the entire watch
face screen so now it'll kind of just
pop right down like a banner
notification on your iphone you guys
know i love tracking metrics and this
has some new sleep stages updates as
well so the apple watch will now be able
to detect which sleep stage you're in it
also has an afib update so the watch can
detect signs of your afib rhythm in
medication tracking this is something
that i never thought that i would be
interested in until i found myself
having to take blood thinners twice a
day and just knowing that now i'm able
to track that on my apple watch and with
my iphone is really awesome you'll be
able to get a notification of the time
you have to take it which medication you
have to take and it's so easy to set up
it's so easy that you can just scan the
prescription bottle and it'll
automatically import it into your phone
this is also pretty cool because it'll
give you drug interactions so if you're
taking multiple medications it can give
you a heads up to say hey you're taking
this and this those two drugs do not go
well together so you might want to talk
to your doctor we've also got some
updates to ipad with ipad os 16. one of
the things that i'm really excited about
is they mentioned that they have a new
iphoto icloud storage so basically you
can set up an icloud storage that you
can invite people to so your friends
your family your partner whatever it is
that you guys want to share you can have
access to that so you can all have one
storage place to share all of your
content also uh there's a weather app on
the ipad i know the crowd is going wild
actually the crowd did go out people
were cheering i think way harder than i
thought that they would for the weather
app on the ipad there's a new
collaboration feature so documents can
be connected to the conversation and you
can even collab working over facetime
especially when you're using freeform
this is like a facetime live
collaboration element which is kind of
interesting and i love that they're
bringing this up because i feel like
people still are working from home and
to people to kind of have this one
shared space you'll be able to see your
co-workers and able to see what they're
working on ipad gaming they showed some
examples of metal three on the ipad
they're also trying to make the ipad a
little more desktop friendly so adding
things like different types of tools
undo redo and making those feel more mac
os like and a little less ipad os this
especially comes in handy when you plug
the ipad into an external display stage
manager is also really cool and this is
kind of giving you another way to
multitask on the ipad they also talked
about this in some of the new mac os
ventura features and they're kind of
bringing all of these together on the
ipad and mac os but still the ipad is
still an ipad one of the fun things that
happens every year is we're like what is
the new mac os gonna be called well my
friends drum drumroll it is called mac
os ventura now we've had big sur we've
had catalina we've had all kinds of
california landmarks and i definitely
was thinking it was gonna be mammoth but
it's not we've got ventura this is also
kind of cool handoff with facetime
there'll be times that i'm on my phone
with a facetime call and then i go to my
computer and i'd like to just continue
that call well now with facetime handoff
we can do that continuity camera this is
awesome they showed this little belkan
attachment that you can attach your
phone to your laptop
and wirelessly use your iphone cameras
to do facetime calls to record video
they also have this really cool thing
which was so mind-blowing you can use
the ultra wide camera while you're doing
your call and see your hands like typing
like you can see the desk view i don't
know how this happens it looked like
magic but it looked like it worked
perfectly of course safari also got a
little updates we have increased battery
life higher quality playback they have
shared tab groups so you can actually be
sharing tabs and see if your friends are
looking at what you're actually looking
at it's kind of neat they also announced
something called pass keys which is
using a cryptographic technique using
touch id or face id and it will only
work for a site that it was created for
it can't be leaked or fished and it
never leaves your device and finally the
public version will be released in the
fall and we all know what that means new
iphones well thank you guys so much for
watching i had so much fun getting a
chance to check out wwc here in person i
look forward to seeing what you guys
think leave me some comments below and
i'll see you in the next video bye
[Music]